a new day a new controversy this morning
over the way President Trump is fighting
the coronavirus late last night he
tweeted this letter that he sent to the
World Health Organization threatening to
permanently cut funding and quote
reconsider our membership in the
organization now the president has
repeatedly claimed that the w-h-o was
negligent in his coronavirus response
and is biased in favor of China the
president also says he's now taking the
anti malaria drug hydroxychloroquine to
help protect himself from the corona
virus now this drug is unproven as a
treatment for the virus and the FDA has
warned it could have dangerous side
effects Paula Reid is at the White House
for us Paula this was an unexpected
development what are we learning good
morning Tony the president revealed that
he is taking this drug as he was being
pressed by reporters about a series of
unfavorable stories he said that he has
taken as if from Ison hydroxychloroquine
and Zink but so far no one at the White
House has been able to confirm the
president's regimen the frontline
workers many many are taking it I happen
to be taking it I happen to be taking it
President Trump says he's taking
hydroxychloroquine and zinc and unproven
combination after hearing anecdotal
evidence hundreds of patients and I give
them hydroxychloroquine I give them the
CPAC which is zero mice and and I give
them zinc and out of the hundreds of
patients many hundreds over 300 patients
I haven't lost one
he claims he requested the regimen from
the White House doctor about two weeks
ago after a support staffer tested
positive for Koba 19 he said well if
you'd like it I said yeah I'd like it
the FDA warned last month that
hydroxychloroquine should not be used
outside of a hospital setting warning of
serious heart rhythm problems in
patients with kovat 19 so far the
president's tests for the virus have all
been negative as scientists continue to
study the drugs effectiveness the
president's endorsement has made it a
political flashpoint we've
tremendous response do dropsy so it's a
very strong powerful medicine speaking
to CBS News in March dr. Anthony foul
she expressed skepticism about its
benefits there is not a proven and
that's the underlying word a proven
treatment or prevention and the
president's critics say he's once again
giving the public bad medical
information every expert who has looked
at it says it doesn't help you against
Kovac so he's giving people false hope
in a carefully worded memo Monday the
president's physician revealed that the
two men discussed hydroxychloroquine and
decided that the potential benefit from
treatment outweigh the relative risks
but it does not specifically say what it
is the president is taking the president
also does not engage in proven
preventive measures he does not wear a
mask and he does not consistently social
distance even those around him it only
started doing so in the past 10 days
Gayle Thank You Paula